et on va plus loin avec à mes côtés
Patricia Lemonia bonjour Patricia et
Bruno Darroux bonjour Bruno bonjour
Raphaël du fromage au vin pétillant
passant par le caviar tout dans le dîner
d'État service ce soir à la Maison
Blanche en l'honneur d'Emmanuel Macron
sera made in USA un patriotisme
économique jusque dans les assiettes et
si c'était ça à la manière pour Joe
Biden d'assumer le procès en
protectionnisme qu'instruit depuis son
arrivée à Washington le président
français des critiques formulées sur
tout hier il faut bien le dire la
journée d'aujourd'hui étant surtout
marquée par un échange d'amabilité entre
les deux hommes écoutés
face au retour de la guerre sur le sol
européen suite à l'agression russe
contre l'Ukraine et face aux prises
multiples qui frappent nos nations et
nos sociétés
il nous faut savoir
redevenir frère d'armes bon il faut dire
qu'il y a elle est un peu fort Emmanuel
Macron hier Patricia Lemonier en
critiquant le caractère déloyal super
agressif des subventions à l'industrie
américaine vis-à-vis des entreprises
françaises ça vous a surpris comme ton
employé à Washington alors le temps
effectivement été vif le moins qu'on
puisse dire mais ce qui m'étonne moi
c'est que ces mesures ont été annoncées
au mois d'août alors j'ai envie de dire
on est un peu lent pour avoir des
réactions vivent si vous me permettez
cette expression c'est à dire qu'il nous
a fallu cinq mois pratiquement pour
reconnaître que les réactions que
l'attitude américaine était agressive je
pense que l'on aurait pu manifester
notre position un peu plus tôt c'est
aussi je pense être déclaration en fait
elle est pas tant à destiné à Joe Biden
parce qu'on sait très bien qu'il va pas
et Emmanuel Macron s'est très bien qu'il
ne va pas revenir sur sa décision elle
[Musique]
sur ce dossier du plan anti-inflation de
Joe Biden tout simplement parce que
l'Allemagne elle exporte des voitures
aux États-Unis et donc elle elle va être
impactée aussi donc Emmanuel Macron il
s'est exprimé un peu au nom des
Européens mais c'est un peu autoproclamé
après qu'est-ce qu'il a obtenu
concrètement on a vu lors de la
conférence de presse finalement Joe
Biden a dit non non mais nous c'était
pas intentionnel vous voulez on voulait
pas nuire aux entreprises européennes il
s'engage même un jobiden à ce que les
créations d'emplois aux États-Unis ne se
fassent pas aux dépens de l'Europe mais
comment peut-il le garantir ça bah je
pense qu'il ne peut pas le garantir donc
il a il a essayé de d'aplanir un peu les
choses en disant voilà on voulait pas
faire de mal aux Européens d'ailleurs il
y a une commission en quelque sorte une
commission mixte des équipes américaines
européennes qui vont parler il a quand
même dit les États-Unis en gros n'ont
pas l'habitude de s'excuser donc on va
pas s'excuser il y a des erreurs
techniques voilà il a dit il y a des
erreurs techniques dans le texte qu'on
va il a dit vous savez quand on fait un
énorme plan comme ça il a rappelé que
c'était un plan à presque 400 milliards
de dollars bon bah on le fait c'est
compliqué avec le Congrès etc en gros on
mesure pas toujours les conséquences
voilà ce qui s'est passé n'y voyais pas
de mal et donc on va essayer d'arranger
les choses mais en fait on va quand même
faire notre plan avec quand même le fait
de privilégier les voitures électriques
les batteries que ça produit aux
États-Unis il faut que 40% des
composants soient produits quand même
aux États-Unis donc en fait il a pas
reculé il a lâché deux ou trois petites
choses quoi ça fait deux fois qu'il
s'excusent un Joe baldom parce qu'il
s'est excusé pour laquelle
il y a eu des erreurs des erreurs pardon
non non pas s'excuse non non excusez-moi
pas c'est moi qui m'exprime ça fait deux
fois qu'il confesse une erreur
excusez-moi une erreur sur cet accord
une erreur de communication à l'époque
de l'accord hocus il avait parlé d'une
erreur
ça comme ça mais en fait ce qui est ce
qui est important dans cette histoire
c'est c'est en fait cet accord
c'est très simple au mec vis-à-vis du
Mexique et vis-à-vis du Canada il y a
des exemples donc si on est amis
avec le Canada avec le Mexique on peut
aussi être ami avec l'Europe mais
au-delà de ce plan parce que on joue pas
dans la même cour les États-Unis en une
force de frappe colossale pour aider
leurs entreprises à s'engager dans le
renouvellement des des énergies mais
donc on ne joue pas dans la même cour
mais ce qui est important dans cette
histoire qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est
que non seulement il y a ce méga plan ce
que j'ai envie de dire mais il y a aussi
le prix de l'énergie
auquel nous vend les États-Unis
c'est-à-dire que regarde naturelle 10
fois plus cher que ne le paye les
amortisseurs
ça peut être aussi la faute des
containers
et des opérateurs qui parmi ces
transporteurs il y a effectivement des
transporteurs français mais le croire
que l'Europe n'a pas de moyens justement
c'est faux parce que nous avons le
champion des transports maritime en
France donc si on voulait G les
Américains se lancer dans une guerre
qu'on ne veut surtout pas parce que les
Européens détestent et ne veulent même
pas imaginer que l'économie puisse être
de la guerre économique on peut très
bien faire pression sur les États-Unis
avec nos transporteurs mais ça on ne le
fera jamais mais l'Europe n'a toujours
pas admis que l'économie le chien
économique les transactions économiques
la croissance peut être un terrain de
guerre les Américains practent cette
guerre depuis Nixon et régal en Europe
on croit toujours à cette vieille idée
comme quoi l'économie le marchandage les
échanges amènent la paix ça marche à
l'intérieur de l'Europe ça marche pas en
dehors et puis les Européens ils sont un
peu prisonniers chez sans doute ceux qui
sont le plus prisonniers de la fameuse
idéologie libérale parce que voilà parce
que Bruxelles dire sous la pas trop
d'intervention de l'État concurrence des
loyal etc les Américains qu'on présente
comme les parangons du libéralisme quand
il faut c'est alors ils mettent des des
centaines de milliards de dollars sur la
table d'argent public pour soutenir
leurs industries donc ils sont libéraux
mais jusqu'à une certaine mesure
l'histoire de Boeing heureusement et
d'Airbus qui sait pas trop mal fini mais
les subventions qui avaient mis les
Américains sur Boeing était
impressionnantes alors il a aussi été
question à un dossier qui intéresse là
aussi les deux pays c'est l'Ukraine et
de ce point de vue-là Emmanuel Macron
qui souhaite continuer à parler la
Vladimir Poutine il va le faire
d'ailleurs il l'a dit à son retour de ce
voyage-là il ne l'obligera en aucune
manière
volodimeersky à faire des concessions
qui ne souhaiteraient pas faire écouter
le président français président zenitski
depuis son élection jusque au mois de
février dernier il n'a eu de cesse de
vouloir négocier celui qui a décidé de
lancer une guerre c'est le président
Poutine
j'en étais le témoin direct voilà
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron a un fléchi
d'une quelconque manière la ligne de Joe
Biden lorsque ce dernier déclare se
déclare à son tour prêt à contacter
Poutine si et à condition bien sûr c'est
une position forte que ce dernier
cherche un moyen de mettre fin à la
guerre ce qui vit cette psychologie
actuelle semble pas franchement dans ses
dispositions
en fait non Jo Biden je pense qu'il a
pas voulu être trop désagréable avec
Emmanuel Macron qui continue à parler à
Vladimir Poutine alors Macron lui il a
dit qu'en fait ça faisait partie des des
objectifs un peu de la France et
peut-être de l'Europe dans cette guerre
évitez tout un Scala d'un contrôlable et
puis nous serons là pour bâtir la paix
alors il a pas une mauvaise intuition
certains jours ou l'autre faudra bien
parler à Vladimir Poutine et puis les
Européens géographiquement sont quand
même bien plus directement concernés
parce qu'il se passe en Ukraine que les
États-Unis Joe Biden lui quand même si
on écoute vraiment à la lettre ce qu'il
a dit ce soir il a dit oui moi je suis
prêt bon à parler à la ligne Poutine si
en gros il reconnaît qu'il a perdu et
qui retire ses troupes donc à ce
moment-là je serai prêt à lui parler
pour pour qu'on se dise des choses mais
pas avant donc en fait il y a toujours
une approche quand même très différente
entre les États-Unis et les européens
notamment les Français sur la question
ukrainienne l'impousserait à affaiblir
au maximum la Russie à ce que l'Ukraine
ne fasse aucune concession finalement
remporte cette guerre en se
réappropriant l'intégralité de son
territoire ce serait Joe Biden l'autre
Emmanuel Macron voudrait maintenir un
canal de négociation avec Vladimir
Poutine et pousserait zellinsky à
négocier quitte à entériné le statu
quotéritorial actuel on aurait tort de
résumer l'opposition franco-américaine
sur ce dossier à ça Patricia Lemonnier
il y a des postures j'ai envie de dire
différentes alors Emmanuel Macron lui
s'est affiché depuis le départ
effectivement comme quelqu'un qui
voulait œuvrer à la paix non tout en
respectant les décisions qui avaient été
projet 7 en mars dernier
c'était l'Ukraine qui déciderait une
fine et de du moment où elle voudrait la
paix mais manuel Macron toujours
européen effectivement proche de
l'Ukraine veut aller pour la paix Joe
Biden lui il poursuit la ligne qui s'est
qui s'est définie avec un petit bémol
ces militaire qui sont un peu fatigués
de donner d'envoyer des armes et qui se
disent je voudrais un peu d'abord
regarder des stocks pour Taïwan si un
jour ça claque et puis mes stock se vide
et mon industrie américaine ne les
remplit pas complètement donc il y a une
forte pression côté militaire pour que
on tempère les ardeurs de de zzky en ce
qui concerne la reconquête de l'Ukraine
mais voyons on rentre dans une période
difficile en ce moment et donc il faut
d'abord voir ce qui va se passer sur le
front
différence aussi c'est qu'en fait dans
cette affaire les Américains se disent
qu'ils sont peut-être à cause des
erreurs finalement de Vladimir Poutine
qui sont peut-être en train de régler le
problème russe donc
jusqu'où pouce en fait est-ce que est-ce
qu'ils vont complètement démolir
l'armée russe et donc du coup la société
russe le système politique russe avec
des conséquences un peu incontrôlables
ou est-ce qu'à un moment on siffle pas à
la fin non pas de la récré ce serait pas
la fin de la partie en tout cas avec en
plus effectivement ces problèmes de
stock qui s'écoule et on fait quand même
pression ils ont déjà commencé à le
faire sur Zelinski pour dire bon bah à
un moment là il va falloir quand même
négocier et à ce moment là pardoncement
la position française reprend un peu
d'intérêt puisque on négocie les
Ukrainiens officiellement feront comme
ils veulent parce que c'était eux qui
vont négocier avec les Russes et puis il
y a une autre petite différence entre
les Européens les Américains c'est que
Macron a parlé quand même d'une paix
durable pour la sécurité du continent
européen ça c'est quelque chose qui est
important pour lui c'est faire en sorte
autant que faire ce peu que ce qui s'est
passé là ne puisse plus reproduire si ce
n'est que les Russes n'envisagent pas la
peine sur le continent europ pas du tout
de la même façon que nous puisqu'ils
veulent une autant complètement avec un
rôle réduit ce qui est uni en tout cas
l'Europe et les Américains au-delà de la
menace russe c'est aussi la rivalité
imposée par la Chine même si les
autorités chinoises semblent remises à
quelque peu leurs ambitions économiques
ces temps-ci quand elles ont forte à
faire à tenter d'éteindre les
manifestations contre la politique zéro
covid une politique que Pékin a
justement décidé d'assouplir par
endroits écouter ce que disait tir la
vis première ministre sur la Commission
nationale de la santé
le pays fait face à une nouvelle
situation et à de nouveaux défis en
matière de prévention et de contrôle de
l'épidémie alors que le variant au
micro-ondes coronavirus est moins
pathogène que la population est vaccinée
et que nous avons acquis de l'expérience
concernant la manière de contenir le
virus et puis ainsi donc le confinement
en place depuis plusieurs semaines a été
levé à Canton ou d'ailleurs avec opposé
des manifestants force de leur mardi et
ce malgré à un record de contamination
là-bas le signe que
Pékin peut plus ignorer le
mécontentement ni se contenter de le
réprimer Patricia
je crois que le régime chinois a compris
qu'effectivement il fallait bouger un
parce que la façon dont il gère le virus
chinois enfin micro-ondes et
préjudiciable pour son économie et c'est
vraiment ça qui intéresse et puis parce
que il fallait en finir avec ses petits
manifestants parce que qu'est-ce que
c'est que quelques milliers quand on a
un milliard et quelques habitants à
milliard 4 qu'est-ce que c'est que ces
manifestants donc aujourd'hui je pense
que le régime pratique
comme on dit chez nous la politique de
la carotte et du bâton en quelque sorte
répression massive sur les manifestants
avec tout l'arsenal pas besoin de taper
en Chine on a l'arsenal de
reconnaissance faciale on a tous ces
Arsenal là donc pas besoin d'aller on
peut réprimer massivement d'une autre
façon et puis
allégé un peu effectivement comme vous
le dites le dispositif sur le covid et
en maniant deux outils
faire en sorte que la peur un peu change
et vous voyez on le dit très bien au
micro-ondes finalement c'est pas grand
chose d'un seul coup alors que c'était
terrible avant mais les Chinois il y a
des Chinois dans les campagnes sont
terrorisés par omégaie il y a eu vivre
dans la peur comme on les a mis à
effectivement il faut maintenant sortir
de la peur donc maintenant on voit ça
sur l'équivalent de Twitter shit du
Twitter chinois et bien faut plus avoir
peur c'est rien et l'autre jour c'est
effectivement vacciner vacciné les plus
anciens qui eux n'ont pas leurs trois
doses et oui parce que l'autre
changement c'est qu'on accélère la
vaccination des plus âgées encore
insuffisante c'est ce qui a révélé cette
crise finalement à la phase du monde
Bruno le taux de couverture vaccinale
insuffisant chez les plus vulnérables
oui oui parce que en même temps les
autorités chinoises étaient un peu
coincées sans doute le sont-elles encore
un peu parce que en fait leur vaccin le
vaccin chinois était pas terrible quoi
comparé au vaccin à RN messager
occidentaux et puis insuffisamment de
Chinois ont été vaccinés notamment dans
dans les populations les plus âgées donc
ces deux facteurs conjugués ont fait que
sans doute les autorités chinoises se
sont dit en fait on maintient la
politique zéro covid parce que vu
l'ampleur de notre population si ça se
met à partir en vrille si vous me passez
l'expression ça va être absolument
terrible là il y a quand même une
manifestation alors je suis d'accord
avec Patricia c'est quelques minutes
manifestants mais je pense quand même
s'ils allègent c'est parce qu'ils savent
que ça peut augmenter ils veulent
absolument éviter à essayer de de calmer
ça tout de suite quand même parce que
sinon ça va devenir un petit peu
problématique et du coup bon ils vont
augmenter la vaccination il y a une
chose qui veulent pas faire encore par
nationalisme
et orgueil c'est importer des vaccins
occidentaux qui sont quand même plus
efficaces
les trois doses apparemment du vaccin
chinois si ils ont trois doses sont
efficaces par contre deux doses ce n'est
pas effectivement efficace et encore la
survivance notamment d'une médecine
traditionnelle en Chine qui fait
barrière et peut-être que l'État n'a pas
suffisamment non plus promu ses vaccins
auprès de auprès de ces populations
évidemment et puis surtout il y a pas du
tout les structures comme chez nous et
pas etc où on ressent les gens restent
dans leur famille très dans des familles
très attachées à la tradition et surtout
autre chose de santé ne les ont pas
entre guillemets sous la main pour
pouvoir les vacciner une dernière chose
c'est que il y a aussi une un respect
énorme des anciens films qui n'existe
plus du tout dans nos sociétés et donc
on vénère ses anciens et si l'ancien dit
je ne veux pas te faire vacciner et bien
la famille s'exécute imaginez-vous c'est
ça chez nous si on en est vraiment pas
là en tout cas cette crise elle aura
permis de démystifier ce qu'on attribue
à l'efficacité en Chine oui alors
politiquement c'est quand même pas très
bon pour chez jimping qui en plus
c'était
quasiment identifiés à cette politique
zéro covid c'est pour ça aussi outre
tous les éléments sanitaires qu'on a
qu'on a invoqué c'était la politique
donc forcément qu'il y avait raison du
président presque de on a envie de dire
du Grand Timonier mais bon voilà
référence à Mao donc chez jimping donc
il ne peut pas se tromper donc il ne
peut pas s'être trompé donc maintenant
on va prendre avec un Manu envoyer vous
avez vu le communiqué de la vie première
minute c'est la pure longue de bois pour
dire que finalement le vaccin est passé
dangereux etc mais en aucun cas nous
remettre là en cause la politique qui a
été menée parce que chez jimping quand
même en interne il joue gros il a été
reconduit à la tête du parti communiste
mais quand même en éliminant tous les
tous les autres clans il y a eu quand
même je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
la manière dont l'ancien président a été
sorti de la salle du Congrès ça veut
dire quand même qu'il y en a qui qui a à
l'intérieur du parti communiste pas mal
de clan qui ont sans doute qu'il
n'attendent qu'une occasion pour essayer
de faire sa peau ce sera un peu trop
fort mais de régler des comptes avec
le régime pique donc il doit il doit
quand même il doit quand même faire
attention politiquement aussi merci
Bruno merci également Patricia lemonière
c'était on va plus loin rester avec nos
prochains journal dans 3 minutes
merci beaucoup